et dans l'actualité également si le
monde d'après n'était pas si vert que
cela on a beaucoup dit que les français
des grandes villes en manque d'air pur
allaient se ruer sur les campagnes après
le confinement mais avec quelles
conséquences sur l'environnement
ce bout même l'annoncé de la
rurbanisation alimenté par une hausse de
l'épargné ménages pourrait au final être
plus polluants qu'attendu on voit ça
tout de suite avec l'économiste jacques
sapir en duplex avec nous jeanne bonsoir
bonsoir ses fans il a en jacques
commençons par l'épargné des ménages
qu'on évoquait dans quelle mesure les
français ont ils été fournies avant la
crise ducobu 19 pas fourni fourmies oui
je comprends bien je commandais mais oui
effectivement
les français se sont avérés être de
véritables fourni fourmis pardon du fait
de la crise ducobu 19 et surtout du fait
du confinement
alors il ya des plusieurs raisons qui
expliquent cela il ya le fait qu' ils
n'ont pas pu tout simplement acheter non
ils n'ont pas pu dépenser leur argent
il y avait aussi la crainte évidemment
de l'après confinement de la crise
économique qui allait venir
mais il ya aussi et ça ça on le voit
c'est un changement structurel dans les
pratiques de consommation
et là il faut bien dire que le
confinement a accéléré plus qu'il n'a
révélé mais il a accéléré un mouvement
c'est le fait que et bien voilà les
français surtout les classes moyennes
qui habitent dans les grandes métropoles
sont tombés amoureux de lecture et de la
verdure
sauf que le mouvement qui en découlent
pourraient être tout sauf écologique
alors justement jacques peut-on chiffrer
ce surcroît d'epargne de la crise du coc
vide
oui absolument si on regarde par exemple
les données qui sont fournis par l'insee
des envois que depuis vingt ans nous
avons un taux d'épargné qui oscille
entre eux très et demi et 16% si on
revenait un peu plus en arrière par
exemple dans les années soixante dix
nous avons atteint un maximum de 21%
alors voit bien que là il ya une baisse
tendancielle du taux dépargne autrement
dit
de la part de l' épargne dans le revenu
des ménages simplement pour le premier
semestre de 2020 eh bien on est remonté
à 23%
il y a bien eu de ce point de vue là un
effet confinement alors comment
l'expliquez vous il ya plusieurs
explications la première est déjà donné
c'est le fait que les ménages n'ont pas
pu dépenser leur argent ils n'ont pas pu
consommer alors on aurait pu s'attendre
à ce que avec la fin du confinement
ils reprennent voir il ratera la
consommation qu'il n'avait pas pu faire
pendant les deux mois du confinement et
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
ben non ils ne le font pas bien sûr
qu'il ya une forte reprise de la
consommation mais elle reste inférieure
au niveau qu'elles avaient atteint
justement en janvier-février de 2020
après il ya une deuxième raison c'est ce
qu'on appelle l' épargne de précaution
et bien sûr les français sont inquiets
pour l'avenir
et ça peut se comprendre si vous voulez
quand on voit l'ampleur de la crise les
problèmes du chômage qui sont en train
de nous tomber dessus dont on a déjà
parlé dans cette émission est donc
évidemment pour cela et bien ils
constituent un espèce de deux matelas de
précaution au départ mais il ya une
troisième raison et c'est celle là qui
va être intéressant
c'est évidemment le changement de
comportement dans la consommation
alors justement changement de
comportement jacques faut-il croire
cette nouvelle pendant ce dont parle
beaucoup à nos amis les agents
immobiliers
est ce qu'on y croit faut-il y croire et
bien en fait il ya une étude qui a été
faite par le site de particulier à
particulier
cette étude a été corroborée par
d'autres études qui ont été faites sur
la même chose et on voit qu'il y avait
effectivement un changement alors
franchement il se manifeste par deux
choses la première c'est que il y à bien
une volonté aujourd'hui de me d'acheter
un nouveau bien immobilier que ce soit
un appartement ou une maison a plutôt
des maisons mais la deuxième chose qui
est extrêmement importante c'est que
aujourd'hui
paris est en chute libre en fait la
demande de l'immobilier sur paris baisse
de plus de 10% à
lors que la demande qu'est qui se fait
un petit peu plus loin que paris même
nettement plus loin que paris donc dans
les départements de la grande couronne
voir au delà vers la normandie ouvert
l'yonne et la bourgogne est bien là la
demande elle explose
absolument alors effectivement jacques
est ce uniquement le chaos en région
parisienne nous avait dit que non a
priori non effectivement et c'est aussi
un autre aspect extrêmement important on
voyait que ça touche pratiquement la
totalité des métropoles françaises lyon
bordeaux même marseille et nice mme on
voit que tous les départements qui se
situe d'une certaine manière
au delà je dirais de la sphère immédiate
de la métropole
eh bien ces départements font l'objet
d'une demande extrêmement fort et on
peut le comprendre parce que ça veut
dire que là et bien les ménages pourront
acheter à un prix à peu près comparable
à ce qu'ils avaient dans la métropole à
la fois une maison mais aussi un petit
jardin alors deux mois de confinement ça
donne ça jacques comment expliquer ce
mouvement
oui évidemment la première raison c'est
bien entendu l'impact du confinement un
impact du confinement qui a été assez
mal vécue en réalité par la population
si vous voulez parce que bien sûr on
peut pas s'auto confiné nécessairement
dans des belles maisons peut pas s'auto
confinés dans des riads j'ai vu qu'il y
avait un certain nombre de personnalités
people qu'il avait fait et bien non
c'est pas ça la vie des français et bien
le fait que le confinement et était
plutôt mal vécu a donné en réaction
cette demande effectivement pour des
logements essentiellement des maisons
individuelles qui soit à la fois
spacieuse parce qu'il faut de l'espace
en cas d'un nouveau confinement et qui
soit à la campagne
alors tout ça évidemment on ne peut le
trouver qu'en allant dans une zone de 50
à plus de 100 km loin de la métropole
et puis une deuxième raison c'est
l'impact du télétravail avec le
confinement les ménages alors
essentiellement les classes moyennes
parce qu'on voit bien que le télétravail
ça peut pas s'appeler
et dans toutes les professions loin de
là mais pour les classes moyennes
l'expérience du conte finances a été la
découverte massive du télétravail et
donc les gens se disent voilà je peux
travailler à la campagne je ne suis pas
obligé d'être dans une grande ville pour
faire mon travail et mes jacques quelles
seront les conséquences de ce mouvement
alors oui c'est cela qu'il faut
maintenant regarder la première
conséquence est bien c'est que
mécaniquement cela va provoquer un
accroissement du parc des voitures
individuelles vous savez quand vous
vivez comme cela à la campagne eh bien
il faut au minimum deux voire trois
voitures par ménage ce qui n'est pas du
tout le cas quand on vit dans une
métropole
après il y à une deuxième conséquence
qui est tout à fait évidente c'est le
fait que énergétiquement une maison
individuelle est toujours moins
efficientes évidemment à qualité
comparable mais elle est toujours moins
efficientes qu'un petit immeuble et donc
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que non seulement on aura un surcroît de
dépenses en énergie du fait de la
multiplication des voitures mais on aura
aussi un surcroît si vous voulez de
consommation en énergie du fait
justement de cet habitat en maison
individuelle
il ya une troisième conséquence c'est le
fait que ça va pousser à une
individualisation de plus en plus
importante de la société
il faut quand même se souvenir que le
mot citoyen vient de citer que la police
grecque nous a donné aussi la politique
et là on voit bien qu'on va aller vers
une société qui sera de plus en plus
individualités alors en conclusion
jacques diriez-vous que l'épidémie de
kobe 10,9 à aggraver ton cela oui c'est
ce qu'il faut quand même si évidemment
le pire est loin d'être sûr
vous savez cette épidémie due qu'aux
vives 19
elle va provoquer des comportements qui
vont pas du tout dans ce sens par
exemple
ce qui a été décidé dans la la
commission citoyenne sur dans la
convention citoyenne pardon sur le
climat et ça risque de nous conduire à
une société qui soit plus individualisée
à une société où des comportements qui
sont extrêmement destructeur en termes
d' usage de l'énergie par la voiture
individuelle 1 par la maison
individuelle vont se multiplier
il était c'était déjà un petit peu le
cas avant le confinement mais voit bien
que là il ya des comportements qui sont
en train de se massifier et puis
évidemment il y à ce très gros problème
comment continuer à faire société et de
ce point de vue là il est tout à fait
évident qu'il faudra repenser non pas un
habitat individuel mais repenser la
fonction des petites villes et des
villages pour essayer de reconstruire du
lien social et bien jacques le tableau
que vous dressez n'incite guère à
l'optimisme et il semble réaliste
espérons vous ayez quand même un petit
peu tort merci à vous en tout cas
jacques à bientôt sur rt france